ja rückblick auf den Wahlkampf ich habe
mich schon etwas gewundert dass im
Wahlkampf kaum eine Rolle gespielt hat
die Frage womit verdienen wir in Zukunft
in unserer Volkswirtschaft das Geld was
wir dringend brauchen um alle
öffentlichen Aufgaben und Ausgaben
seriös finanzieren zu können ich habe
immer auch mit guten Argumenten gehört
wir müssen mehr tun für Bildung für
Forschung für Rente für Soziales für
pflege ich dachte jetzt gleich kommt's
wie stärken wir die wirtschaftliche
Leistungsfähigkeit unseres Landes wie
stärken wir die Einnahmenseite kam aber
nicht das sind zwei ganz fundamentale
gegensätzliche Positionen was schafft
Wohlstand das ist die Umverteilung
natürlich immer von oben da unten oder
ist es Fleiß ist es die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit ist es die
Innovationskraft eigentlich müssten auch
die größten Anhänger der Umverteilung
wissen du kannst nur das umverteilen was
vorher im Land erwirtschaftet worden ist
und wie wir das schaffen die Debatte
wünsche ich mir
also ich stimme Ihnen in allem was Sie
gesagt haben komplett zu dieser
Wahlkampf war ein Ausgaben Wahlkampf
gegen niederrum eigentlich mal zu
überlegen wie muss das was dann Ausgaben
propagiert wird finanziert werden und
vor allem wie kann man möglicherweise
bei den Ausgaben auch ein bisschen mal
auf die Bremse treten also ich bewunder
die deutschen Steuerzahler muss ich
sagen das sind ja die größten
Masochisten eigentlich mittlerweile ist
21 jahrhunderts wird eigentlich nur
genommen man muss sich beschimpfen
lassen als Steuerzahler aber ein dank
der Politiker gegenüber Steuerzahlen hat
es noch nie gegeben und ich glaube was
Sie ansprechen ist vollkommen richtig es
muss so etwas geben wie einen
Wahlprogramme Check lässt sich das was
beispielsweise Linkspartei die Grünen
aber auch die Union im Wahlkampf
propagiert und verspricht lässt sich das
eigentlich finanzieren oder nicht die
Niederlande haben so etwas da gibt's ein
Institut das berechnet seit zwei
Jahrzehnten jedes Wahlprogramm durch und
sagt ist plausibel ist nicht plausibel
lässt sich finanzieren lässt sich nicht
das brauchen wir ja auch ja wir können
diese Rechnung zumindest insofern dass
vielleicht dann die Steuerprogramme der
Parteien durchgegangen werden und dann
heißt ja also nach dem Programm würde
dem Staatshaushalt würden so und so viel
mehr Milliarden oder auch weniger
reinkommen aber das ist natürlich immer
ein wahnsinnig multidimensionales System
weil es dann nicht mit einrechnet dass
ja dann zahlt man vielleicht weniger
Steuern das kurbelt aber die Wirtschaft
auch wiederum an und so weiter na also
es gibt also viele Unsicherheiten in so
einer Rechnung aber ich habe schon auch
den Eindruck gehabt den den Bosbach
formuliert dass man über das Ausgeben
von Geld sehr sehr freigiebig spricht
und über die Notwendigkeit die
Wirtschaft zu stärken wenn überhaupt
dann immer nur so ein bisschen verschämt
und klammheimlich und wenn es dann um
die Frage geht wo soll das Geld
herkommen na ja dann ist ein Vorschlag
der durchaus auf dem Tisch lag eben
schlichten ergreifend mehr Schulden
machen Schuldenbremse aufweichen ja das
ist ja ein weg und ich glaube das
Politiker inzwischen in gewisser Weise
enthemmt sind denn sie wissen ja es ist
auf jeden Fall genug Geld da nämlich
unseres also ich glaube dass bei allen
Bekundungen zum Trotz und mein sozusagen
letzter großer Ritter in dieser
Situation ist dann Christian Lindner der
sagt keine Steuer Steuererhöhungen und
nur mit diesem Blick sehe ich Ihnen
jetzt durch die koalitions Sondierungen
dann tapern in den nächsten Wochen da
wünsche ich viel Spaß denn es wird doch
nur darum gehen wie man die
Steuererhöhung nennt und nicht das ist
nicht Steuererhöhung heißt also es wird
irgendwo muss er Geld herkommen das weiß
ja jeder Mensch
der Unternehmer also ich würde sagen wir
brauchen nicht mehr Geld also wir haben
wirklich wir sind ja jetzt schon fast
schon Steuer
Weltmeisterschaft
ausgegeben ich glaube das wirklich mit
der fest Überzeugung dass der Staaten
schlechter Unternehmer ist und wir nicht
mehr Einnahmen braucht sondern dass die
Ausgaben besser kontrolliert werden
müssen und das glaube ich würde ich auch
an Christian Lindner Stelle wirklich bei
den Fahndung auf dem Tisch bringen und
mal sagen wie ist denn die
corona-rechnung wo wurde was ausgegeben
weil wenn man Steuererhöhung fordert
finde ich muss der Staat erstmal zeigen
ich habe das Geld was rein kann gut
ausgegeben nur dann kann man verlangen
dass mehr Geld reinkommen werden die
Summen um die es da geht dreistellige
Milliardenbeträge die da jetzt sozusagen
weg sind die müssen irgendwo wieder
herkommen also außer meine gesamte
wirtschaftslogik als aus dem kleinen
Karo eines minihaushälters ist
durcheinander irgendwoher muss das ja
kommen und meine Prognose ist völlig
klar es wird von uns kommen ist nur die
Frage ist ein bisschen so wenn du dir
und das Beispiel hängt in gewisser Weise
natürlich aber wenn du dir acht neue
oder sag mal zehn neue Autos kaufst dann
sagst du auch das Geld für diese Autos
das muss irgendwoher kommen die Frage
ist natürlich müssen es so große Autos
sein die Luxusausstattung sein brauchst
du auch den Fuchsschwanz am Spiegel oder
geht's auch ein bisschen kleiner diese
Frage muss man sich zu mein Auto das ist
die Menge und den Fuchsschwanz
die sechs Autos oder 18 okay aber den
Fuchsschwanz
ihre These ihre Sendezeit brauchen wir
mehr Geld
oder besser wirtschaften das eine
schießt ja das andere nicht aus was mich
nur wundert ist wenn zum Beispiel ist ja
als ein klassisches Beispiel wir
brauchen mehr Geld für die klassische
Infrastruktur Straße Schiene Wasserwege
für die digitale Infrastruktur für den
Wohnungsbau der Bund der Steuerzahler
hat die Abrechnung für 219 vorgelegt von
16 Bundesländern haben 13 die zur
Verfügung stehenden Mittel nicht
aufgebraucht weil es an Baurecht fehlt
weil bei Klagen eingereicht werden also
das hemmt ja alles und bei den
atemberaubenden Zahn Corona Hilfspakete
national und europäisch das wird in
Aussicht gestellt wir müssen in zwei
drei Jahren mal fragen was davon
tatsächlich abgeflossen ist der Staat
hat ja noch im Moment Glück mal wir ja
für die Kredite die wir aufnehmen so gut
wie keine Zinsen zahlen also wenn wir
die Zinsbelastung noch hätten bei dem
wir gehen ja jetzt knapp auf 3 Millionen
Neuverschuldung hoch
2,62,7 dann hätte ja selbst ein
wirtschaftlich starkes irgendwie
Deutschland erhebliche Probleme wir
nehmen ja ohnehin immer ungefähr als
ohne Corona 200 Milliarden Schulden auf
im Jahr warum weil für 200 Milliarden
Schulden tilgen warum weil wir dafür
drei vier Prozent bezahlt haben und für
die neuen Schulden nichts mehr das hilft
im Staat im Moment tilgen muss also und
so aber wir sehen ja immer wieder wie in
die eine Tasche gegriffen wird um es
dann mit der anderen Hand wieder neu zu
verteilen bestes Beispiel ist das Thema
Grunderwerbsteuer das können die
Bundesländer zwar Regeln je nachdem kann
man seinen eigenen Satz festlegen liegt
derzeit zwischen dreieinhalb und
sechseinhalb Prozent je nach Bundesland
immer auf den Kaufpreis obendrauf das
heißt die Länder Schrauben ist nach oben
um dann aber das natürlich dann Bund
aber eine Eigenheimzulage zu beschließen
das heißt ich mache das Kaufen einer
Immobilie teurer als Staat und sagt dann
oh mensch das ist so teuer das können
Sie jetzt immer weniger Leute leisten
also nehme ich Geld und gebe es
denjenigen die sich dann Immobilien
nicht mehr leisten können weil sie
vorher eine Art mit verteuert hat das
ist doch schizophren
da kommt noch hinzu dass es mal eine
höhere Steuer gab ich glaube die war
sechs oder sieben Prozent mit unzähligen
Ausnahmevorschriften und da hat der
Stand gesagt die Ausnahme weil jeder
versucht hat unter einer Ausnahme
Klausel zu kommen die Ausnahmen
streichen wir und senken die Steuer ab
dann haben wir die Ausnahmen gestrichen
aber die Steuer erhöht dieser
Widerspruch lebt in uns wir wollen also
das ganze bauen angeht das soll
energetisch sein das soll modern sein
wir verteuern das Bauen aber die Mieten
sollen deswegen die steigen es ist
vieles widersprüchlich das stimmt
geworden
[Musik]